I'm delighted to introduce our speaker
sasha Rockland of UPenn is now also
spending time at MIT he'll be telling us
about algorithms for learning on graphs
thanks for the invitation pleasure to be
here
the mic is on right okay okay so I will
talk about work with karthik city tehran
we've been working for a while on
problems of online prediction online
learning and today what i will discuss
is just as like a very easy example of
just a snippet of the
results and you know if you're
interested in the all the gory details
you can i can refer to the papers so on
purpose i want to make this very simple
and simplicity is my goal here all right
so
if you think about the the usual
prediction paradigm that we have an
emotion learning it's always to you know
collect some data then estimate some
model and then make prediction based on
the estimate of the model and so for the
problems that we're interested in in
this talk this middle part the the
estimation of a model somehow is a hard
computationally hard problem
computationally hard objective and so
the question is whether one can directly
go to prediction avoiding the model
estimation part and if you would like to
have a takeaway from from this talk is
that yes in the problems that we will
consider it's possible to predict even
if estimation is np-hard so somehow by
avoiding estimating the model going
directly for prediction we can still
have a computationally efficient
algorithm and and this idea is perhaps
not new if you think about the
beginnings of machine learning in the
60s you know that the kind of people
realize that if you know if you want to
distinguish male versus female faces
let's say then you don't have to
estimate the model for the distribution
of the male faces in the model of the
distribution of the female faces and you
go directly directly for the boundary
between the right if prediction is your
goal right so go for the simpler problem
rather than solving the more difficult
problem along the way okay so what I
would like you to keep in mind is kind
of this problem you know there is a
fixed social network and and one by one
we have to make predictions about labels
let's say binary labels or multi class
labels for each person so think of this
person is opening a Facebook page you
need to design a system that will
display ads and so you need to predict
you need to classify this person as type
1 type 2 or you know out of multiple
types and and then you learn the outcome
whether the person clicked or and didn't
click on the ad so what let's just say
it's a full information setting so you
actually learn the the the true label
and and you go on and so forth so
you move within the network and the
prediction should be made based on the
site information that the node so you
have some information about the
covariates for the person a male female
gender age and so forth based on graph
connectivity okay so that should be
taken into account and the information
that you've gathered so far so this is
the problem kind of a running problem
and you know the question is you know
how should we model this problem let's
say we want to solve the problem how
should we approach this problem well we
can we can you know if we're Bayesian
maybe it where's the decisions we would
like to pass it a probabilistic model
for instance community detection is is
one example if you would think that
there will be two communities one is you
know prefers to to buy this type of
product this refers to type to buy
another type of product maybe that's a
community detection model perhaps we can
phrase it as a huge dynamic program and
somehow figure out the optimal way to to
predict at every time step and so forth
you know so so what are the computation
efficient methods one can just try to
run batch algorithms at every time step
such as laplacian regularization and and
and hope for the best
okay and again the question here is is
estimation versus the prediction do we
need to actually estimate some model do
we have to posit a model an estimated or
can we just bypass estimation another
word that I'll be using is proper versus
improper learning so proper meaning you
first estimate a model and then give out
the prediction according to the model
improper avoids this step and what we
will do is we will model solutions just
like in the example of faces male versus
female the solution is a hyperplane will
model the solutions rather than the
process that generates the data and what
we will have is there is a knob that
trades off computation and the
statistical performance so let's be a
bit more precise you know if you're not
concerned with computation then
in the online learning community what we
like to prove is that our average
prediction error is upper bounded by the
Oracle error that's the comparator
that's the the best you could have done
in hindsight if you had had all the data
and plus a little of one remainder and
the hope that this goes to zero at a
certain rate so that's if you don't care
about computation now suppose that
Oracle error
you can't compute that so this is an
np-hard problem even in hindsight with
all the data you can't compute it but
you know you can say if suppose that we
have a alpha approximation for the
Oracle loss for the for that offline
problem then you would like to have
alpha times
well you might hope to get alpha times
Oracle error and this something like
this has been done for instance in the
paper of Kalai circadian Liggett what we
will do is by avoiding model estimation
we're gonna get Oracle error with a
constant 1 so it's 1 times opt + and
alpha will only enter in this lower
remainder term ok so and this at this
point that seems very strange why would
this be possible to do but I will
describe it in such a simple terms that
you will see that it's actually kind of
obvious why this should be the case okay
why is this result not too interesting
in the sense that well it's you know it
could very quickly be vacuous so suppose
that the Oracle error in terms of
prediction is 5% prediction error right
and alpha typically we have a
multiplicative approximation of analog
square root of log N or you know some
factor 2 then quickly this becomes
you're comparing yourself to some very
high numbers the result quickly becomes
vacuous ok so I will present the results
through the lens of this very classical
result of Tom Kover in 1965 I guess this
paper is almost unknown
the result of it is very simple yes
slightly different frame we're going to
talk about prediction there's going to
be the indicator loss it's not it's not
the general online problem right that's
correct it's gonna be a prediction
problem that's right
okay so I will describe everything
through the lens of this result let's
let's describe the most basic sequence
prediction problem you can have there is
a sequence of bits y1 through yn plus
minus 1 and we would like to make
sequential predictions y hat 1 up to Y
hat n where the predictions are causal
so the Y hat T only depends on the bits
that have been observed so once you make
a prediction
suppose that you observe the outcome
right away make a prediction Y hat 1
observe the Y 1 y hat - observed Y 2 and
so forth so the goal is to have a small
number of prediction errors okay that's
the goal so can we predict the sequence
so what you know fix any algorithm
randomized our non-randomized any
algorithm will be worse than something
worse on some sequences and better on
some other sequences if it is better on
some sequences it has to be at the
expense of being worse than some other
sequences okay maybe it's not too
obvious but if you think about averaging
this quantity over 2 to the N sequences
and then carefully switching the
expectations you see that in expectation
over the hypercube on average over 2 to
the N sequences this quantity has to be
1/2 so there is there is no free lunch
right so if you the algorithm is better
on some sequences it has to be at the
expense of being worse on some other
sequences but the the kind of the
interesting question which was asked by
Tom cover is is the converse if I tell
you which sequences I care about can you
construct an algorithm right so that's
that's the interesting direction so any
algorithm induces a profile on the
hypercube that's the expected number of
mistakes on on on every corner of the
hypercube and every vertex of the
hypercube
and the the opposite is if you I tell
you this function on the hypercube is
there an algorithm that achieves that
function so let's make it make it a bit
more precise we'll say that the function
fee is achievable if there exists a
randomized strategy it has to be
randomized so we have to work with
randomized strategies such that for any
sequence y1 through yn that's my
notation for a sequence y1 through yn
they expected under the randomization of
the algorithm average number of mistakes
is upper bounded by the function of that
sequence ok so that's what it means for
a function view to be achievable now
let's only consider fee such that when
you flip one bit it's it's it's a
function on the hypercube so when you
compare the function values along the
edge the difference is no more than 1
over n if you consider these functions
then the result of cover says that he is
achievable there exists an algorithm if
and only if on average over the
hypercube
these are random occur and inverse plus
or minus one uniformly and independently
is at least one half okay so whenever
you take a function you check that its
expectation on a uniform distribution
over the hypercube is more than one half
there exists an algorithm that will
achieve that function so anyone here can
prove it
the proof is about one page you just sit
down and write it as a kind of work
backwards and then the cover didn't even
actually prove it but he just stated
that it's obvious but it actually
requires a little bit of a proof so let
me just make a note that this is the
simplest example of an interesting
phenomena that I think we'll only
formalized a year ago that existence of
prediction algorithms is equivalent to
probabilistic inequality so that's an
interesting phenomenon so just to give
examples interview we think of experts
the experts algorithm the exponential
Waits algorithm I think it's kind of a
fork result that it's equivalent to a
Union bound right so the expected
maximum of n sub Gaussian random
variables is square root of log N and
that is exactly the square root of log n
that appears in the in the exponential
ways and if you go through the proof at
some point you use exactly the the kind
of the the Union bound for sub Gaussian
random variables but this equivalence is
actually quite a bit more general so
there's a paper that we posted it's
called an equivalence of probabilistic
inequalities and deterministic regret
statements all of these results are
deterministic per sequence and these
results are probabilistic and and so
there are some examples there were for
instance
gradient descent can be shown to be
equivalent to inequality I'll bounce
four ratios of a norm of a sum of random
variables divided by its variation
spirit of the sum of the increments yes
statement about efficiency or is it
simply that they're made it seems to be
that it could involve something that was
computationally intractable yeah there's
nothing about computational efficiency
here there is nothing right
that's a good question or just existence
of algorithms okay so you know this is
just to maybe to pique your interest but
uh yes yeah well if to take any function
that whose is expected less than one
half what's that so suppose we're trying
to predict take the minimum of the
proportion of ones in the sequence and
the proportion of minus ones okay if you
check the expected value of that
function it's actually less than one
half and I'll give argue I'll give
plenty of examples you'll see okay so
somehow this magic happens for this
particular setting binary labels
indicator lost no covariance and what
we've been kind of working on is to
characterize what is possible wouldn't
the community is not just us the you
know under which conditions can can we
get algorithms or prove their existence
and again so it led us to some
interesting martingale extensions of
empirical process theory the certify
existence of algorithms okay so here's
the canonical construction we need to
pick a function whose expected value is
more than one half and the canonical
construction is to take a subset of the
hypercube
so that's let F be a subset of the
hypercube and
let Phoebe a normalized Hamming distance
to this set okay so that's a canonical
construction this is the one that has
been studied within the online community
for the last 20 years okay
let me say let me say this again why are
we doing this so the result of cover
says that you know any algorithm is
basically there is no free lunch though
any algorithm will have 1/2 average
error on all the sequences but we want
to turn the tables and we want to say
okay we're actually going to use this
function feed to model the problem in
other words we don't care about all the
sequences right we only care about some
sequences we want we could model this
probabilistically
which would lead to a completely
different set of results or we could
model it through this function fee as a
set of possible solutions and yes this
function fee we're gonna make it small
on those sequences that we care about
and it will be at the expense of being
large on some other sequences but we
don't care about those sequences we're
not gonna see them right that's kind of
the the rough idea yes yeah so many
people ask this so I don't know how to
formally relate this because these
results are completely deterministic but
I think yeah you couldn't think of that
as a maybe the set that you expect to
see but there is no problem stick
generative model for this
okay so this is canonical construction
and if you know am i learning you've
seen this before it's just that
rephrased slightly differently okay so
if we take this canonical construction
we need to ensure that the expected
value of V is at least one half but if
you look at the this function fear as a
Hamming distance you see that it's
expected value I is not one half it's
less than one half right if the set F is
non-empty than they expected Hamming
distance to the set is less than one
half right
unless it's a thing
but you see that it you know if the set
F is not crazy then it's just small
slightly smaller than one half so you
just need to correct it right so what is
the correction the correction is some
constant right it only depends on the
set F and it's easy to see that the
smallest value of the constant that
makes expected value of V more than one
half is precisely the this random ocker
averages these are called random
occurrences of the set F is a subset of
the hypercube
it's a correlation of elements in F and
random signs oh sorry
yes sorry sorry sorry this should be cm
I changed one and didn't change that
apologies so this should be cm so what
the CN is the average width of F if you
know the Gaussian with this is a very
related concept so somehow it's a you
know the average width of the set F when
you look on average over the directions
towards the vertices of the hypercube
okay again this is not a new result you
can find it for instance in a new colon
Gabor's
paper in the annals of statistics in
1999 for instance just raised slightly
differently okay so these are Rademacher
averages from statistical learning and
just as a side you know there are no
covariance here there is no graph but if
covariance covariance are present then
what you would get instead of this CN
you would get sequential random occur
ever just were again you're correlating
random science with values of the
functions on the data but now these data
is is it's a predictable process with
respect to the dyadic filtration
generated by the same Epsilon's so this
creates a supremo for marking Yale and
and and supreme over a bunch of you know
marking Gayle's index by elements of F
and leads to this kind of extension of
the empirical process theory okay
the result of cover is actually
algorithmic so if you go through the
proof if you actually write down the
proof you'll see that it's algorithmic
and this is the the optimal algorithm
and what does it look like you take the
function fee all right so the
we have to have a randomized strategy
and randomized strategy for predicting
one or minus one is just the mean of the
distribution on plus one minus one and
that's a number between minus one and
one
right so all we have to do to specify an
algorithm is to provide a value between
minus 1 and 1 given the sequence so far
and that's what we're gonna do the that
value is a difference of the fit
function where the first t minus 1
coordinates are fixed then you put a
minus 1 and then you fill the rest with
Quinn flips random plus minus ones and
then from that you subtract the same
thing with a plus 1 so think of this as
a difference of the potential if the
potential here is the same as the
potential here in other words it doesn't
matter whether you put a minus 1 or plus
1 then the this value Q hat is 0 and
that's the unbiased so I don't care
whether I should be playing minus 1 or
plus 1 the the it's an uninformed choice
and then you have to scale by n just to
get to the right scale and this is where
you see the condition of that the
function theif shouldn't change along
the edge by more than 1 over N that's
where this comes in and there is an
expectation over the coin flips into the
future and this just comes out from the
minimax analysis it doesn't and this is
a well-known result this comes out from
the meaning of max analysis it does not
mean that we're assuming future is you
know iid random we're not placing any
assumptions about the actual sequence
that we will see but but this is the
solution that comes out of the minimax
analysis
okay so what do we need to do well we
need to evaluate the the value of fee
function twice and you see the by
linearity of expectation you know you
can just draw these Epsilon's and then
drop the expectation this is a W
randomized strategy that worse works
correctly an expectation and all we need
to do is to compute the Hamming distance
from or compute the value of the
function at this point and at this point
of course that constant that shifts the
fee function doesn't matter right
because it cancels in the difference and
the only thing you need to do is to
compute the Hamming distance from this
point and from this point to this step
that can you took to just see how much
closer on average this one is
and and these predictions are improper
right we're not we're not we're not
finding a model we're not estimating
some model and then outputting
predictions according to that model
we just need to do something right
here's an example
so let's come back to ich heisse
question suppose that you want to
predict the sequence and you think that
it's going to be imbalanced okay so
there will be there will be more once
than minus ones or more minus ones than
one suppose then what you can do is you
can take the set F to be two points one
is the old ones and one is all minus
ones and then this Hamming distance it's
easy to see it just becomes the minimum
between the average of ones and the
average of minus ones that the frequency
of minus one frequency of Plus Ones and
then you need to correct it by basically
square root of log two or some multiple
of that over square root of M now what
is the interpretation well if you use
this fee function in the algorithm it
means that if the sequence is imbalanced
let's say it has 40% ones and 60% minus
ones then you will make only about 40%
errors if the sequence happens to be 20%
80% you will only make roughly 20%
errors and this is not a trivial result
right I mean if you think about trying
to design such a method there is no
stochastic City in the in in the
sequence of course if you knew its
Bernoulli you just you know estimate the
bias and then proceed with the majority
but you can you get essentially the same
result without an assumption about the
generative process of the sequence okay
and there is a nice paper I guess it's
one of the last papers that David
Blackwell wrote in 1995 that basically
discusses this interesting duality
between assuming the generative process
for the sequence and then having a
deterministic algorithm or having a
randomized algorithm that works for any
sequence right and the results that you
get are the same
okay so yeah so I should say that here
it's easier to see that any algorithm
that you you you come up with has to be
randomized because for any deterministic
algorithm there exists the sequence that
with exactly does the opposite of what
you're going to predict so there is no
way to achieve this result of the
deterministic method okay so what would
are some graph-based functions for you
so now we want to bring the graph into
the picture let's start with this kind
of community detection style picture
this is the you know the data set that
was beaten to death by the community
detection community this is the
political block data set has lots of
Democratic blogs that link to each other
and then Republican blogs that link to
each other and this data set is at least
twelve years old maybe more and there
are fewer edges in between so what what
do we expect well if we think that we
want a model homogeneity of labeling
with respect to a graph then it's
natural to define the set F as those
labelings those are these are vertices
of the hypercube such that the value of
the laplacian is less than some value
Kappa ok that's a modeling choice so
here's the laplacian I'm sure all of you
know there is just the diagonal minus
the adjacency and you can have a
weighted laplacian as well if these are
trust distrust networks with possibly
plus you know - weights indicating a
repulsion and plus weights attraction
and more generally this is an example of
what's called the CSP in the computer
science community where you can define
the set F to be those labels the
labelings over the nodes such that some
kind of a some of the constraints is not
to violated not too much violate them
there's a more general formulation
so in this example an the length of the
prediction problem is the number of
nodes we're assuming that you will just
go through all the nodes and make
prediction one by one okay so this cut
bait cut based constraints very quickly
become np-hard and it's easy to see it
so for instance if you take weighted
undirected graph and define the way to
laplacian this way then evaluating the
Hamming distance is as hard as computing
the minimum of this quadratic form and
then that becomes a min uncut if you
take weights to be minus 1 and so this
the essentially evaluating the Hamming
distance is an np-hard problem ok so
that's what I promised in the beginning
we have a natural formulation where you
would like to to predict as well as you
know the best labeling that is smooth
with respect to the graph in a certain
sense but the problem is np-hard
and the first idea is to just
approximate this Hamming distance and
and and there are multiplicative
approximation algorithms but I do not
know how to use such an approximation
result within the prediction setup right
so you know you need to compare the
Hamming distance from two points to the
set and it's not clear what having an
approximation buys you maybe there is a
way to do it but we don't know but I
will show you in a way that gets around
that problem so it's still possible to
get the mistake bound and the idea is
very simple you you know so suppose that
this set F is difficult to compute the
Hamming distance to and you take a
larger set F prime so that you have a
relaxation and then it's easy to see
that if you define the function V prime
now with respect to the distance to this
larger set then of course the Hamming
distance now goes down because it's a
larger set but there's this rad amok
averages the width of the set becomes
larger and so of course trivially its
upper bounded by the Hamming distance to
the original set and this number became
became large how much larger was just
the average of the the expansion right
how much did we lose in making this set
F larger and so you already see the kind
of why the approximation only enters in
this lower order term it doesn't enter
you still have one times the opt right
this is the prediction error compared to
the one time's up and this factor began
becomes worse so what's interesting is
is to see how much this factor becomes
worse and so do we have an example where
where we can control kind of how much
worse this factor is in particular in
particular we would like to have a
trade-off between accuracy and
computation so this idea that you take a
larger set F and you get you know better
computation but perhaps worse guarantee
on the number of mistakes another
interesting observation is that we only
need the value of the relaxed problem we
don't need the integral solution so we
don't need to round the the solution to
be integral which is of course a big
part of the work in the computer science
community okay so let me summarize for
the particular example of CSPs if we
have a alph approximation algorithm for
the CSP then we will have the number of
mistakes that our method makes compared
to this combinatorial objective and this
is the larger little of one factor and
how much larger we will see now that
it's the width of a set where the number
of constraints is enlarged by alpha
alpha being the multiplicative
approximation the integral the gap
in that CSV problem you are trying to
label plus one minus one the whole
hypercube or F so what's the connection
to and so so basically the the canonical
way to define a function fee is to take
a subset of the hypercube and now this
subset of the hypercube is going to be
given by a by this type of CSP
formulation where we only look at those
labelings that do not violate the
constraints very more than a Kappa and
now we would like to see how relaxing
the set effects the computation and the
present precision any other questions
so the vertices are all the labelings of
all the n elements and what you observe
is one more coordinate at the time
okay so this is how we bound the the
width of the larger set versus the width
of the original set so I don't know if I
should go into this basically we lift
the problem into a semi definite
relaxation or you know sum of squares
whatever lacera hierarchy whatever you
want so we write as SDP but you know
this can be this kind of analysis works
for a general way to solve the
combinatorial problem so you go to this
is the original problem you would like
to maximize beta I should say that the
the Hamming distance the calculation of
the Hamming distance is equivalent to
maximizing a linear function so you can
see that so you can extend it to the
root to the RN rather than the hypercube
this is the original problem where it's
still over the comunitario set subject
to a linear constraint being at least
beta so it maximize beta that's the same
as maximizing the linear constraint and
the the dual problem for this is the
minimization of the constraints subject
to the objective value being more than
beta so you can relate the opt one to
opt tool and now for this opt to use is
where we use the integrality gap we're
assuming that there exists a way to
minimize this CSP by going to what what
are called su the distributions maybe I
don't have time to to go into these and
then from this SDP to we're going back
to the SDP one the set F prime is never
actually explicitly defined it can be
seen as the projection of this higher
dimensional object but we don't have to
define it explicitly and so if alpha is
the integral T gap between these two
problems which is well studied in the
computer science community then you get
the the value of CN prime is the
Rademacher averages of the set F where
the number of constraints is enlarged by
alpha okay so this is just a simple
calculation right any questions about
this
the way the way that alpha thus
integrality gap enters is through the
number of constraints that are violated
exactly so the whole point here exactly
that the predictions are improper I'm
not trying to find a max cut and then
output some prediction I just need to
evaluate the fee function I just mean
that that real number right and that
real number can be evaluated using the
approximation algorithms but not
directly but in the in this dual problem
where it's the number of constraints
being unsatisfied or satisfied
freshness
well this light are you taking the
assumption that at prime as an SDP
relaxation of ebb Kappa as an
illustrative example of relaxation are
you saying that you're appalled it's
only when F prime is an SDP relaxation
no so this is just an a way to relate so
this is just an example of how to how to
use the integrality gap in the analysis
to understand how the set F and F Prime
in terms of the width are related
okay so now the question do do we have
these algorithms that will give us that
alpha and the into integrality gap and
if one looks at the for instance
guruswami seen up as a general result
for quadratic integer programs right
we'll be minimizing quadratic subject to
linear constraints and and it shows that
if you if you spend you know end to the
our time and is the the size of the
problem then the integrity gap is the R
inverse of the earth roughly inverse of
the earth
I can value of the of the laplacian of
the normalized laplacian one can also
use metric labeling relaxation so it
doesn't have to be as DP one can work
with the LP relaxation z' and here we're
looking at a slightly different problem
where the constraints are penalizing
rather than being hard constraints
an interesting feature of this is that
you don't actually need the rounded
solution as I'm as I mentioned before
you just need the value and so you know
in some sense if in a week someone
proves a titer result for for the
integrality gap well we just plug it
into the theoretical bound the algorithm
doesn't change right it's just like a
generalized EP relaxation okay so let me
skip the the results that let me just
say that we implemented the the
algorithms without hoping to that it
will work but it actually works very
well and it seems to outperform the
Laplace in the regularization or are the
methods that are really not tailored to
online problems they are tailored to a
batch problem right so you can of course
you can implement the try different
methods and hope that they work but they
probably have been developed for the
offline problem where you have lots of
data and you try to to learn from these
data and and and and here we're just
going after the exactly what we want
right we're minimizing exactly the the
function that we want to minimize the
number of mistakes we're modeling
solutions if you think about the kind of
philosophically we're modeling the set
of solutions rather than the process
that generates the the data and this is
the online learning philosophy one can
say that this is an epic framework but
this function fee is exactly reflecting
our knowledge about the world right
we're not trying to do something for
free we're choosing this fee function to
correspond to what we think is happening
in the world for instance the the
labeling should be a smooth with respect
to the graph
and the predictions are improper and
this is this is key so let me just a
sketch give you a sense of how this can
be extended we've extended these results
to cite information that the nodes
general cost functions you can work with
the evolving network whose generative
process you you know or you can estimate
and I think the interesting result in
our impartial information where you know
you display the the advertisement but
you don't know if the person didn't
click you don't know the value or you
know the kind of observations are
censored so if you have site information
at the nodes the protocol is that you
observe the site information the person
you make a prediction and then you
observe the outcome and typically in
machine learning people pause it a class
of functions support vector machines
neural networks whatever that you hope
are capturing the relationship between x
and y and the question is how to merge
these two sources of information the
graph based information and the
information in the covariance and and
this is one way to do it you can look at
the projection of the function class
onto the data and that's a subset of the
hypercube now this mark might be large
and so you hope that the graph now
narrows down the set so the network
constrains when you intersect them with
constraints from the function class are
hoping in making the set of labeling
smaller right so now you would like to
do as well as this set of set of labels
and we have experiments where you can
tune the parameter how much the
algorithm relies on the information and
the covariance and the information from
that coming from the network and as you
tune that parameter the algorithm either
goes after these this information or
after the information than the network
so you can see that if you the network
has for instance the small cut so you
you're just a few notes within one
community is enough to start filling in
the other nodes then
these Network constraints are kicking in
if somehow the covariates provides you a
lot of information males are buying this
type of product and females are buying
another type of product then these
constraints are kicking in ok so a
general setup is through what we call
relaxations and this idea is not it's
not new so what we want is we want a
strategy that depends on the covariates
observed so far and the labels observed
so far such that for any outcome that
will come you make a prediction you
observe the outcome the loss this is a
loss function that compares the
prediction and the the outcome is
bounded by the difference in the
potential okay so suppose that you can
come up with such functions fee if you
can do that then of course everything
telescopes and you get V 0 minus V n and
this is the the analog of the feature is
data independent that's the constant
right
that's how much you have to correct it
and the minus VN is basically the
hamming distance okay so that's the
analog for a general relaxation so we
will say that fee is admissible if for
any X T when you take the minimum over
possible predictions and the maximum
over possible outcomes the loss plus the
potential is no more than the potential
at the previous step so this is kind of
a standard thing in online learning if
we if we ensure that fee n is at least
this comparator this is the performance
of the functions the best performance of
you know these experts in the class F
that map side information into
predictions then then function is
admissible and then it can be used for
prediction and the whole question is how
to come up with these potential
functions so what we have is kind of a
set a toolkit for deriving these fee
functions using techniques and
probability theory so the symmetrization
sequential scimitar ization
and so forth so admissibility can be
checked by marking Gail inequalities and
sequential symmetrization
what's interesting is that you know that
the function fee just like in this
example the set F permit Rises the
algorithm right once you fix this F or
once you fix this fee that gives you an
algorithm exponential way it's great in
this and whatever and so we have kind of
a we have a way to to move in the space
of algorithms right there is some kind
of algebra of these relaxations where
you can take two relaxations combine
them and so it's nice that you have some
kind of basis in which to move in terms
of algorithms the possibilities when you
have a partial information that
miscibility condition becomes like this
that he is now evaluated that the
information that you have so far so you
might not observe the actual outcomes
but you observe some partial information
and and this becomes the miscibility
condition so let me spend maybe two
minutes on contextual motor and bandit
which can be solved at least some extent
using the same machinery so suppose I am
a host at the party I have to serve
drinks and people come to me one by one
and I offer them a drink and there are D
drinks the options that I have and of
course the usual motor MANET says that
the classical multi-armed bandit says
that there is one drink that's best for
all people but of course that's not the
case right you have some the drink type
should depend on whether maybe the
gender may be some other characteristics
of the person so I should make my
decisions based on what I see about the
person coming to me and I'm I'm okay
assuming that the COBE areas are iid so
these people just come from some pool of
people at the party and but I don't want
to make assumptions about the costs so I
observed the cost whether the person
like the drink but I don't want to make
any a stochastic assumptions about
these cost and will model this in terms
of this individual sequence prediction
setting where you make no assumptions on
the costs and what you would like is to
have a average cost of your decisions to
be compared to the best policy that what
would have happen have had you follow
this policy that map's covariates to
decisions of which drink to serve and
then the cost of that drink of course
you don't observe the outcomes for the
drinks that you have insert so this
becomes a explore exploit problem and
it's it's it's been it's been a hard
problem so that there is very slow
progress on this on this problem
precisely because it's not clear what to
do in this case the space of algorithms
somehow is not is not so clear right in
the iid case we know what to do
basically you need to estimate something
but in this individual sequence scenario
the contextual bandit has been a
difficult problem so long story short we
need to show that some key function of
information is admissible in the sense
that I showed before let me not go into
the details and that leads to a simple
bister algorithm that gets a bound for
for this contextual manner problem
suppose the now you want to take the
network constraints into account so you
can intersect the values of the
functions of the nodes with the
constraints for instance you can model
things like I think there will be a part
of the network somewhere where people
will like this product this could be a
bunch of combinatorial structures within
the within the graph and you can easily
put that as a constraint okay so let me
conclude I think we have new avenues for
the development of online methods the
simplest one being this fee function
that arises from this
cover result 50 years ago there are some
well-established probabilistic empirical
process techniques to help in developing
these efficient algorithms what I
presented today's is hopefully an
example of marriage of an approximation
algorithms and online relaxations so I'm
hoping to get the you know computer
science theory people interested in this
in this set of problems we have act and
a knob for accuracy versus computation
and I guess the main thing here is that
the the predictions are improper and
that's what drives the the computational
efficiency so there is a tutorial that
we put up online with basically what I
would I discussed today there is a book
draft that you know will take some years
to complete and maybe I put up some open
problems so I think it would be
interesting to develop linear and sub
linear methods for large-scale graphs
the problem that I described in the
beginning I think is very natural it's a
sequential decision problem and we would
like to be linear or sub linear in the
size of the graph and right now the the
you know we're we at least need to
invert some matrix and so that we can't
go more than you know 10,000 nodes for
instance I think it's interesting to
develop results for evolving graphs
where you don't know the evolution of
the graph but the graph changes as you
go I think it's interesting to explore
which fee functions in terms of modeling
are good in practice and lead to good
predictions and practice it would be
interesting to get up you know a partial
from a complete story with partial
information I just sketched a brief
result in that direction
that should be enough thank you a couple
quick questions yes yes so we got 3/4
then if this was a within a few months
using very similar techniques improved
by vassilis and co-authors and Rob's
appear and quarters to two thirds and
we're working on trying to get it to one
half which is the power 1/2 which is it
should be we're not there yet
the VIX related to like sort of the
width that arises in like step packing
covering problems is there some
connection between these two I don't
know
let's thanks I'll show again